script or budget what should someone
think of first when producing a film
karen i love your questions i really do
the business side of me says budget but
you can't ever deny script script is
look it
here's what i say to filmmakers i say
you got to be cognizant of how much you
spend because there's only so much you
can make back
but don't if you're if you want to make
money with a movie don't make a bad
movie
like there's no point in doing something
that's not going to entertain an
audience
if it's if it's a piece of crap then
if you're doing it because you want to
practice fine but if you're doing it
because you really want to try to give
yourself a shot
don't do a bad movie because a bad movie
can't sell
it's just so you can't compromise on
script for the sake of budget
but there's a range you see script is
not just here
it's a range it could be this is good
enough this is fantastic
so maybe you hopefully end up in the
middle or somewhere here
but you know at some point you have to
say okay i can't afford all the things i
want in here because my budget won't
allow me all these explosions or
gunshots or you know in the case of an
action movie all the stuff you want to
stick in here
but i have enough story here where i'm
prepared to go
at this level and i feel like i can make
a good solid
entertaining movie in the case of budget
though you see
if you want to make your money back
there are certain realities to the
marketplace that
there's certain levels where it's tried
and true that you're only going to make
a certain amount back on certain
levels of movies like for instance if
you're not using a level talent
you're just using no name talent it
peaks out at a certain level unless you
know
we're i'm not talking about the
anomalies the home runs that come in the
left field that you
nobody expects it okay i'm talking about
the regular everyday movies
all right for the most part you're only
going to get back
say this amount of money for for for a
budget
at this like make a million dollar movie
chances are
the highest prospect you have is a
million and a half dollars out there
if you and if you think that's a million
and a half is what i can really get
once you creep you start creeping that
budget up to a million two three
four five or go over that
even if you are super successful the
market won't bear anything more than
that
therefore you're putting yourself in a
predicament where you probably won't
make money
where you could have made money if you
stuck to that million dollar budget
now then it becomes script like your
filmmaker there's the integrity i need
that one extra explosion
i need that one extra big scene you know
to make this movie more epic and
maybe win an award or something like
that and maybe it
does make the movie better but i'm not
sure it increases the revenue on the
back end
until you get into sort of the next
category of film
so i tend to lean budget is always the
controlling factor because
because i don't want to lose money but
script is a very very
they're related right what can you do
it's basically the question
always is here's how much money
realistically
you have to spend either because that's
what investors gave you or that's
you don't want to spend more because
that's what you can earn back what can i
do
in this story for that amount of money
will i feel
compromised that i couldn't do enough
don't make that movie then
let me see if i understand this so if i
have a film and i know that the budget
is a million dollars
great stay at that level because there's
there's a chance i can recruit my
investors money and and
make a profit but if i start to move the
needle and do a few more things here and
we're going up now 200
000 now i'm putting that money at risk
there's a chance that
that's not going to be a safe investment
but if i had an uh what would be the
higher
the next highest so two million yeah
it's categories so first of all and
again it's not a perfect science it's
just based on my experience right
so this a classic filmmaker will say you
know like let's use a million dollars
right you're making an action film for a
million dollars
all right you really want two million
dollars because you want to add in all
these other
big you know special effects and stuff
like that but you don't have it
the distributor says a million and a
half is
the realistic place that revenue that
we're gonna get for this movie
so try to keep it there once you start
spending that extra they then you
here's what a filmmaker says but if i
spend an extra 200 000 i put that big
scene in that big explosion scene then
you're gonna get two million for the
movie not 1.5
and the distributor says maybe we know
we're going to get 1.5
we might get two but if we don't you've
just eaten up 200
000 worth of profit of your profit so
do you want to take that chance and then
the filmmaker says yeah because i know
what's going to happen and the
distributor says well we've sold
500 movies like this and it's only
happened for one
what you know you're sure you want to
roll the dice on that because
it's a very very risky decision so i
tend to be super pragmatic and i say
it's not worth it's not worth the
business side of it
let's just talk about budget for a
second right
there's there's so many ways to make a
budget all right
let's talk about three classic ways to
make a budget this is this is the crazy
part about it
like i keep saying okay a million
dollars because it's a round number
right
so how do you get to a million dollars i
mean the classic way that's taught in
film school and that most filmmakers use
in studios use this is the classic way
you take the script you break it down
you schedule it you break it down into
shooting days all your elements your
locations you know your actors all the
kind of stuff you do as a script
breakdown right and from that you see
what it's going to cost you budget all
the elements and then you come up with a
number
and let's say that number is a million
two
by somebody doing it the proper way by
doing it that way
that's what i call front end budgeting
all right
a million two is the number right now
there's some wiggle room here or there
you know
you're gonna use this car that blow up
or something else or whatever there's a
few things that you know come into play
but a million two is your number right
then here's another way to do it you say
that realistically your uncle
left you a million dollars and that's
the
only amount of money you're going to
have to spend nobody else is going to
ever give you another dime
you have a million dollars to spend but
you just got a budget for a million too
does that mean you don't make the movie
or does it mean
that your financial resource is a
million dollars so you figure out how to
cut out two hundred thousand dollars and
now your budget's a million dollars
so that's what i call back-end you have
a million dollars now you want to just
make as good a movie as you can for a
million dollars do you do it
like that's the question right then the
third way
is what i was talking about before which
is
the market the people who do the
marketing say
the most you could possibly sell this
for is you know a million three
so don't spend more than a million
because we're going to need some 300 000
of wiggle room or something like that
if you want to be financially successful
and which you do
so now you go with the market and they
say you can't
spend more than that that's that's what
you have to make this movie for in order
to be
successful which one do you go with your
filmmaker which one do you go with
the first way at a million two is where
are you gonna get the money from
like is somebody gonna actually finance
it the second way somebody said i got a
million dollars you spend a million make
a good movie we're good to go
the third way is you're being super
fiscally
it's being led by the market conditions
that's a
business decision can you make a movie
that
you know has artistic merit within that
range
so these things all factor in into
this realistically if you want to get a
movie made now
there's a lot of filmmakers who say to
me
this is my script this is the breakdown
this is the number
it's a million seven and there's no
wiggle room
that's the number and i say wonderful
you're probably gonna lose money on the
movie you may never get it financed
but hopefully you will and you'll make a
great movie and
and that's fantastic but you know you
hear the stories of people who spend
10 15 20 years of their life chasing
that dream
um now on the flip side of that
you know there's you're making an action
film and it
requires a million dollars to do it
properly and people say no and i'm gonna
do it for a hundred thousand
and i say that's great do it for
practice because
i don't care how good a filmmaker you
are the chances of you making
a you know the production value style of
what needs to be a million dollars for a
hundred thousand dollars is
extremely low yes people have done it
yes i know
all the examples the el mariachis and
the blair witches and i know all of them
they're anomalies they're one out of
fifty thousand or 100
000 don't make a business decision based
on those
you know people winning the lottery like
everybody talks about the
people who won the lottery nobody talks
about the hundreds of millions of people
who didn't win the lottery
so that's it depends what business
decision you want to make
that was a long answer for that question
how many filmmakers accept that
all studio filmmakers accept it because
they have to because they're
responsible to you know to deliver a
bottom line
and a very small sector of indie
filmmakers accept that
i mean they're forced to accept it
because
if they actually want to make something
that there's only a certain amount of
money that you know they have access to
so i'd say if you want to talk about
compromise in the indie film market
most people are making stuff well and
for budgets well below
what they really should make it for and
then it comes out badly not because
they're not good filmmakers they're
actually really good filmmakers
but they didn't have the resources to
make the film properly so it comes out
badly and then that becomes sort of
their calling card and they made a bad
film and then it's
you know in some ways almost a negative
it's you know it's as crazy as this
sound it's almost better to make those
films and not put your name on it
just do it because you need to practice
and hone your skills but
don't put your name on it because it's
not necessarily your best foot forward
to get money for your next film
i know that sounds nuts but no no i've
heard other
like authors say you know just accept
that your your first book will
not probably probably won't be a
bestseller probably won't do
anything substantial and i think it's
just like reconciling that with yourself
and knowing okay
i'm probably not going to be this
anomaly i'm not going to you know i know
i want to be
but i'm going to accept the fact that i
can still do this but my first one is
not going to be
this like great success yeah but the
beauty of the film business this is what
is so attractive
attractive for the film is it's this
this dream this glamour this glory
i mean it's so infectious you know
people
dream of that and all is i call it the
hollywood dream
that you can be the anomaly you can be
that one
crazy breakthrough hit um
and not not every business has that this
business does offer that
and that's what all indie filmmakers
have that dream
and you know some of them get to live it
not many but some do
sure and then there's just something
satisfying about being in a theater
renting it out
seeing it with an audience having a q a
having an after party
if you're able to afford that and and
being okay with that
yeah you know it's funny what you just
described being in an audience renting
out a theater having a party all that
kind of stuff
that's good the first time around the
second time around
the only thing you're the first time
around you're you're in heaven
you're listening to the audience you're
the movie opens and they clap
and there's a q a and every it's
greatest experience right
the second time around all you're
thinking about is how much that theater
costs you
how much the hors d'oeuvres cost you how
much people are drinking how much
what the bill at the end of the day is
going to be even though you enjoyed the
movie and you enjoyed that but
after a while it becomes like can i
afford this
so the party's fun the first time and
then
the the second third and beyond it it
stops being about
the party's always fun because parties
are fun and you're celebrating a work of
art that you just created
you're you're having a baby like you
just brought a new baby into the world
and that's a celebration so the party's
always fun don't get me wrong i enjoy
every party and i have a party for every
film because i want to celebrate it
that's the celebration
it's not the business though some people
think it's the business
some people think going to a film
festival and sitting through a big
screening and everybody doing the q and
a and everything like that
that's a party and it's a nice party
it's a nice celebration and sometimes
it's the only celebration you get
for me the celebration is getting a
really big check from a streaming
company
because i sold the movie and then seeing
it on the the first time you see it on a
stream
like on netflix or something like that
that's a party
that's a real party i mean that to me is
for me
sitting in my you know family room with
my family and
watching it the first time it comes on
to a streaming company and knowing that
i got paid for it
that to me is a celebration now the
other stuff is really fun
and i enjoy it and don't get me wrong i
like a good party like everybody else
you